this video is my entry for the project
for awesome an annual charity event on
YouTube where we raise money and vote
for our favorite nonprofits to give that
money to I'll reveal which organization
I'm supporting in a few minutes but
first though let me tell you a story
about how powerful the scientific method
can be in the late 90s the Harvard
professor Michael Kramer was interested
in improving education in Kenya instead
of starting an education nonprofit like
you might expect he decided to do a
series of randomized control trials this
is what they entailed he randomly split
up the schools that he was studying in
Kenya into two groups one group would
continue their schooling as usual and
the other group would receive the new
interventions like more textbooks and
more teachers finally he'd compare the
outcomes of the students and provided
the sample was big enough he could
conclude that any differences between
the groups was due to the intervention
as you probably know this sort of
randomized control trial is exactly how
we test if a medicine is effective but
up until this point they were unheard of
in the not-for-profit sector for obvious
reasons of course this intervention is
going to be effective why should we
waste precious resources testing that
well Kramer's idea was not to test all
the different interventions at once but
to test them all in separate trials to
figure out which was the most effective
at improving the outcomes for students
to his surprise one of these factors
worked ridiculously well first they
tested giving out more textbooks then
providing flipped routes for the
teachers and then improving the teacher
to student ratio before I tell you the
results I want you to take ten seconds
now to guess which of these you think
was most effective which one would you
have funded if you had to choose
[Music]
okay let's go through them
pricing Li the extra textbooks seem to
have no real effect a possible
explanation is that these textbooks were
just too high level for the students
anyway especially since they were
written in English the students third
language so then they tried the flip
charts reasoning that the teachers could
tailor the lessons to the students
ability this way again though for
whatever reason this had no discernible
effect on the sample they trailed then
they tried simply having more teachers
but again there was no effect
frustrated that none of these had worked
crema decided to try a crazy suggestion
that he'd received his team gave the
students medicine in school that
prevented them from getting stomach
worms stomach worms are something that
many of us aren't familiar with because
they're fairly rare in developed
countries but they're devastating to a
person's health and far too common in
some developing countries it turned out
many children in Kenya at the time were
missing school because they were sick
with worms
what they found in the trial was that
students who had got the treatment miss
school far less and as a result did far
better in fact when researchers followed
up with the students a whole ten years
later those who had been treated were
earning 20% more than those who hadn't
been
for just fifty cents per child per year
this intervention had had a massive
impact on their lives
the scientific method tells us that we
should make hypotheses about how the
world works but then we need to test
them if they don't hold up no matter how
much it seems like they should be true
we need to abandon the theory and start
the process again in this case you can
see how powerful this process can be
some nonprofit interventions really are
a lot more effective than others so it's
worth doing this sort of rigorous
analysis to find them
to put this into perspective here's some
really mind-bending data
this study compared 108 health
interventions in developing countries to
measure how successful a health
intervention is you want to look at how
many extra healthy years of life it
gives someone one extra year of healthy
life is what we'll call a dally
this study looked at how many delis
$1,000 spent on an intervention would
buy what they found was half the 108
interventions saved people five years or
less of life for that cost in other
words five years was the median value in
this study so you might expect that the
best interventions would then save
around ten to fifteen years at least
that's what I would have guessed but
actually a whole bunch of the remaining
half fall between five years to 100
years which is great but amazingly there
are five interventions out of the 108
that do even better
the best one saved 300 years for every
$1,000 spent a massive bargain compared
to the median of just 5 years the
majority of these interventions work
just ok but some of these interventions
work amazingly well so doesn't it make
sense to find these and fund them that's
why I give well the not-for-profit that
I'm supporting comes in they do
extensive research on these sorts of
interventions and if you donate to them
they give that money to their top-rated
initiatives at the moment that includes
several organizations focused on
deworming treatments but give well apply
the scientific mindset that we should
always be updating our beliefs based on
the best new evidence that's why they
reassess their choices for their top
nonprofits every year and they're very
transparent about how they come to their
conclusions if you want to support this
sort of evidence-based giving there are
two simple things you can do one vote
for them on the project for awesome
website the link is in the description
and to share this video because a lot of
people have the idea that charity is
useless and corrupt I hope this video
convinces you that it certainly doesn't
have to be this way
charity can be an effective way to help
those most in need